♪ ♪
>> Sean: WE BUILD BEGIN THIS
FOX NEWS WERE ADDED TO THE VERY
LATEST DEVELOPMENT ACROSS THE
STATE OF FLORIDA OF HURRICANE
IAN CARVED OUT A PATH OF THE
SCOTTISH INSTRUCTION ACROSS THE
STATES IN THE SOUTHWEST COACHES
AND RUN TO THE CENTRAL PART OF
FLORIDA AND IN THE EAST COAST
LOOK YOUR SCREEN YOU'VE ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES WIPED OUT AND
DESTROYED.
FORT MYERS BEACH IS ABSOLUTELY
DEVASTATED THEIR CONTINUING TO
RECEIVE MORE AND MORE UPDATES ON
THE EXTENT OF THIS DAMAGE AND OF
COURSE THE SEARCH AND RESCUE
OPERATIONS ARE UNDERWAY
FIRST RESPONDERS THEY HAVE
IMMOBILIZED EMERGENCY CREWS IN
THE DOING EVERYTHING THEY CAN TO
RESCUE THOSE THAT ARE TRAPPED AS
RESIDENTS NOW CONTINUE TO SUFFER
UNDER THE DEVASTATING STORM
SURGE FROM NAPLES TO SARASOTA,
FORT MYERS AND BEYOND.
THE STORM IS NOW BEARING TOWARDS
THE COAST OF SOUTH CAP CAROLINA
IT LOOKS TO BE HEADING STATE
STREET TOWARDS CHARLESTON WE
WILL HAVE FOLFOX COVERAGE
THROUGHOUT THE NIGHT TONIGHT.
FIRST AS WE HAVE SHOWN YOU ON
THIS PROGRAM AND AFTER YOUR
PRESIDENT, THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
JOE BIDEN IS NOT WELL.
HE IS WEAK, HE IS FRAIL, FRANKLY
DECREPIT.
HE IS DETERIORATING COGNITIVELY
AT A PRETTY RAPID PACE.
HE IS NOT FIT TO
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF.
YESTERDAY FRANKLY MAY HAVE BEEN
JOE BIDEN'S LOWEST MOMENT YET
WHICH IS KIND OF SAYING A LOT
DURING A WHITE HOUSE EVENT ON IN
JACK JAWORSKI JOE BIDEN CALLED
OUT THE DECEASED CONGRESSMAN AT
ONE POINT SAYING I GUESS WHERE
IS JACKIE?
AND WONDERED WHERE SHE WAS.
WHERE IS SHE SEATED IN
AUDIENCE, TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Biden: ON THINK
ALL OF YOU HERE FOR INCLUDING BY
PARTISANS.
SENATOR BOOKER, REPRESENTATIVE
JACKIE ARE YOU HERE?
WHERE IS JACKIE?
I THOUGHT SHE WAS IN A BE HERE,
TO HATE HELP MAKE THIS A
REALITY.
>> Sean: WHERE IS CUSTOMER NOT
FUNNY.
SADLY THIS MAY HAVE BEEN ONE OF
JOE'S MOST DISTURBING MOMENTS IN
A SINGLE LOT.
REMEMBER AT THE TIME OF HER
DEATH, JOE BIDEN ORDERED FLAGS
TO BE AT HALF-MAST HE DID A
HEARTFELT, AND APPARENTLY HE
FORGOT RUNNING WOULD BEEN A VERY
MOVING AND HEARTFELT TRIBUTE
WHICH IS WHAT ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE.
IN THE WHITE HOUSE THEY TRY TO
PLAY DEFENSE FOR JOE BIDEN THATH
WORSE AND HERE'S JOE BIDEN'S
PRESS SECRETARY RAMBLING ON, AND
ON, AND ON ITS FREE BAD.
CIRCLE THE PRESIDENT WAS LOOKING
AROUND THE ROOM FOR AN AUDIENCE
MEMBER, A MEMBER OF CONGRESS WHO
PASSED AWAY LAST MONTH.
WHAT HAPPENED THERE?
TO GO AS YOU WILL KNOW YOU ARE
WATCHING TODAY'S EVENT VERY
IMPORTANT EVENT, THE PRESIDENT
WAS NAMING CONGRESSIONAL
CHAMPIONS ON THIS ISSUE.
>> SHE WAS SAYING WHERE IS
JACKIE SHE MUST NOT BE HERE.
>> I JUST EXPLAINED SHE WAS ON
TOP OF MIND.
>> IF THE LATE CONGRESSMAN WAS
TOP OF MIND I WAS EXPECTED TO BE
HERE AND SLUICING ABOUT WHY HE
SAY HE WAS IN FOR?
NOT TRY TO BE SNARKY HERE.
I'M JUST SAYING THAT HE SAID
THAT.
>> AGAIN, I THINK PEOPLE CAN
UNDERSTAND.
>> I'M NOT SURE WHY, WHY ONE
MORE TIME.
>> THE CONFUSING PART IS WHY IF
SHE IS TOP OF MIND AS A
PRESIDENT THINK THAT SHE IS
LIVING.
>> I DON'T FIND THE CONFUSING.
>> Sean: EVER WONDER WHY THE
MEDIA MOB WOULD NEVER SPEAK OUT
AGAINST ME POINTING OUT THE
OBVIOUS BECAUSE THEY ALL SAW
WHAT WE SAW.
WE WERE THE ONLY ONES BRAVE
ENOUGH TO SAY IT AND ASK
YOURSELF WHY COULDN'T THE
JOE BIDEN WHITE HOUSE JUST ADMIT
TO THE ERROR.
WHY CAN'T THEY FOR ONCE JUST
KIND OF BE HONEST, LITTLE
TRANSPARENT, TO YOU THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
WE ALREADY KNOW IT IS BECAUSE
THEY KNOW THE PRESIDENT IS A
COGNITIVE WRECK.
THEY KNOW THAT HE IS NOT FIT TO
SERVE THAT'S WHY THEY HIDE HIM,
THAT'S WHAT HE DOES LESS THAN
ONE EVENT ON AVERAGE PER DAY.
THAT'S WHY HE'S AT THE BEACH ALL
THE TIME.
GOD ONLY KNOWS HOW MANY TIMES
HE'S RELEASING DOCTORS.
AND WITH EACH PASSING DAY
JOE BIDEN IS GONE FROM BAD TO
WORSE IN EVERY WAY IMAGINABLE.
WORSE ON STAMINA, WARS AND
ENERGY.
WORSE ON EVERY FRONT BUT OF
COURSE UNQUESTIONING ALLIES IN
THE MOB THE MEDIA I DON'T THINK
IT WAS THAT BIG OF DEAL, BUT
MAYBE WE NEED TO ASK A QUESTION
OR TWO HERE'S HOW THE LADIES AT
THAT HARD-HITTING NEW SHOW THE
VIEW CREATED HIS REMARKS.
LISTEN SPECIFICALLY TO JOYLESS
BEHAR.
>> YOU CAN GO AFTER HIM FOR
FORGETTING THAT SOMEONE IS
PASSED.
SHE PASSED LAST MONTH.
NOT LIKE A HUNDRED YEARS AGO.
OKAY?
TO GO I THINK WHAT REALLY SHOWS
IS THAT THIS COUNTRY SO AGEIST
THIS COUNTRY HAS A PROBLEM WITH
AGE YOU KNOW YOU GO TO OTHER
COUNTRIES AND THEIR ELDERS ARE
REVERED.
THEY ARE REVERED BECAUSE THE
KNOWLEDGE THAT THEY HAVE
ACQUIRED AND THIS IS A MAN WHO'S
WORKED IN GOVERNMENT HIS ENTIRE
LIFE.
>> Sean: ALL WE MISS HER,
AGAIN ENDING DELTA MUCH BETTER
FOR JOE, HE APPEARED TO FORGET
THE NAME OF HIS VERY OWN EMAIL
ADMINISTRATOR AND THEN AIMLESSLY
ONCE AGAIN WANDERED OFF SHAKING
AIR IN THE USUAL THING THAT HE
DOES IS VERY AWKWARD AND
EMBARRASSING.
UNFORTUNATELY HIS
VICE PRESIDENT, SHE IS NOT DOING
A LOT BETTER BECAUSE AGAIN TODAY
ANOTHER WORD SALAD SHE FOUND A
WAY TO LET SAY EMBARRASS THE
ENTIRE U.S. ON THE WORLD STAGE,
SHE WAS VISITING THE DMCA
PROCLAIMING THAT AMERICA HAD
ALLIANCE WITH NORTH KOREA LITTLE
ROCKET MAN, KIM JONG UN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> Vice President Harris: THE
UNITED STATES SHARES A VERY
IMPORTANT RELATIONSHIP, WHICH IS
AN ALLIANCE WITH THE REPUBLIC OF
NORTH KOREA.
IT IS AN ALLIANCE THAT IS STRONG
AND ENDURING.
AND TODAY THERE WERE SEVERAL
DEMONSTRATIONS OF JUST THAT.
>> Sean: THE BLUNDERS FOR THE
WHITE HOUSE DIDN'T STOP THERE.
THE VICE PRESIDENT HAD THIS
AWKWARD MOMENT WHILE OBSERVING
THE DMZ.
AGAIN, DID SHE KNOW ANYTHING?
ABOUT WORLD EVENTS, HISTORY,
WHAT IS SHE DOING?
WHERE SHE GOING?
WHO IS SHE TALKING TO CUSTOMER
TAKE A LOOK.
♪ ♪
>> IT'S 50 METERS AWAY.
>> THAT'S IT, THAT'S IT.
>> Sean: THERE YOU HAVE IN
AMERICA THESE ARE THE FAR LEFT
FAILURES THAT ARE RUNNING YOUR
COUNTRY AND ITS BITE DEMOCRATS
ARE THAT DESPERATE TO DISTRACT
FROM JOE BIDEN'S DISASTER AS A
PRESIDENT AND OF COURSE
DESPERATE TO DEMONIZE
REPUBLICANS OF ALL COSTS HERE IS
JUST A SMALL SAMPLE OBAMA SAYING
ALL REPUBLICANS DON'T LIKE JOE'S
BORDER POLICY BECAUSE THEY DON'T
WANT PEOPLE OF DIFFERENT COLOR
COMING INTO THE COUNTRY CLINTON
COMPARING A TRUMP SUPPORTER TO
AND THE BIG BAD MEGA REPUBLICAN
SPEECH.
>> THE BIGGEST FUEL BEHIND THE
REPUBLICAN AGENDA.
AS RELATED TO IMMIGRATION.
IN THE FEAR THAT SOMEHOW
AMERICA'S CHARACTER IS TO BE
CHANGED IF THE PEOPLE OF DARKER
SHADES AND THERE'S TOO MANY OF
THEM HERE.
>> THERE WAS A RALLY IN OHIO THE
OTHER NIGHT DONALD TRUMP WAS
THERE RANTING AND RAVING FOR
MORE THAN AN HOUR.
AND YOU HAVE THESE ROADS OF
YOUNG MEN WITH THEIR ARMS
RAISED.
WHAT IS GOING ON?
>> President Biden:
DONALD TRUMP AND THE REPUBLICANS
REPRESENT EXTREMISM THAT
THREATENS THE VERY FOUNDATIONS
OF OUR REPUBLIC.
>> Sean: DEMOCRATS THEY CAN'T
RUN ON THE RECORD AND IF THEY
CAN'T RUN THE ECONOMY, A 40 WHEN
YOU'RE HIGH OF INFLATION.
THE CAMERA BORDER SECURITY,
2 MILLION AND WE HAVE ONE
QUARTER LEFT IN THE AIR.
THIS WILL BE THE BIGGEST YEAR
FOR ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IN THE
COUNTRY'S HISTORY.
HE CAN'T RUN A FARM POLICY, THE
CAN'T RUN ON THE RECORD ON
CRIME.
DEFINE, DISMANTLE, AND OBEY ALL
LAWS.
THE CAN'T RUN ON THE STUDENT
LOAN FREE HANDOUT RECORD.
THE CAN'T RUN THE RECORD ON
ANYTHING.
THE PRICE OF GAS, THE CAN'T RUN
ON THAT EITHER.
SO ASK YOU AGAIN TONIGHT BECAUSE
IN 40, WHAT TWO DAYS NOW?
ARE YOU BETTER OFF NOW THAN YOU
WERE BEFORE JOE BIDEN TOOK
OFFICE AS YOUR PRESIDENT?
ARE YOU BETTER OFF INTO THE
SURGING INFLATION, THE SINKING
401(K)s?
ARE YOU BETTER OFF AT THESE
HIGHER GAS PRICES, ARE YOU
BETTER OFF PAYING HIGHER PRICES
FOR EVERYTHING YOU BUY EVERY
STAR YOU GO TO?
ARE YOU BETTER OFF WITH OPEN
BORDERS?
ARE YOU BETTER OFF WITH FENTON
ALL POURING INTO THIS COUNTRY?
HUMAN TRAFFICKERS, FUELING CRIME
AND CHAOS ALL ACROSS THIS GREAT
LAND OF OURS?
ARE YOU BETTER OFF AND THE
GLOWING THREAT OF NUCLEAR WAR?
ARE YOU BETTER OFF UNDER
JOE BIDEN'S WEAK DIPLOMACY?
CAN YOU NAME A SINGLE THING THAT
JOE BIDEN HAS DONE TO MAKE YOUR
LIFE BETTER?
HAS HE DONE ANYTHING TO IMPROVE
THE COUNTRY?
THIS ONE THING?
JOE BIDEN, KAMALA HARRIS,
NANCY PELOSI, CHUCK SCHUMER?
THEY CAN'T GO ONE DAY WITHOUT
BAFFLING BLUNDERS IN BIZARRE
WORD SALADS AND EMBARRASSING THE
WHOLE COUNTRY.
THEY CAN GO ONE DAY WITH
BASICALLY SLANDERING, SMEARING
REPUBLICANS, CONSERVATIVES, AND
DEMONIZING CONSERVATIVES.
THEY CAN GO ONE DAY WITHOUT
SURRENDERING THEIR AGENDA TO THE
FAR LEFT CLIMATE ALARMIST
RELIGIOUS CULT BASE.
THEY RUN THE PARTY.
THEY ARE HELL-BENT ON DESTROYING
OUR WAY OF LIFE, AND DESTROYING
CAPITALISM.
IN 40 SHORT DAYS, 40 DAYS, NOT
42.
YOU GET THE FINAL SAY.
YOU GET THE SEND THE MESSAGE.
THIS IS YOUR OPPORTUNITY TO GET
THIS COUNTRY BACK ON TRACK.
THESE FAR LEFT, SOCIALISTS
DISASTERS ARE NOT THE DIRECTION
THAT WE NEED FOR THIS COUNTRY.
INSTEAD, WE SHOULD RUN AN AGENDA
CENTERED AROUND LAW AND ORDER
AND SAFETY AND SECURITY.
IT SO CAN PURSUE HAPPINESS.
BORDER LOSS, NATIONAL
SOVEREIGNTY.
ALL OF THESE THINGS WE TALK
ABOUT EVERY DAY.
YOU HAVE TO CONTROL OUR BORDERS.
WE NEED BACKGROUND CHECKS,
HEALTH CHECKS DURING THE
PANDEMIC, MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
WON'T BE ABLE TO TAKE CARE OF
THEMSELVES FINANCIALLY.
THEY WILL BE A BURDEN ON THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I WOULD FIXING THE DISASTER OF
OUR EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM?
OFFER A CHOICE TO PARENT AND
EDUCATION.
HOW ABOUT LESS GOVERNMENT
TAXATION, LESS GOVERNMENT
BUREAUCRACY.
NONLEGAL BACK TO THE TRUMP
POLICIES OF